good morning John so if you asked me a
couple of years ago what I thought the
most deadly infectious disease in the
world was I probably would have started
out with malaria and then if you told me
I was wrong after that I probably would
have gone to AIDS and then yeah I would
have needed a hint you know I would have
needed a hint to get to tuberculosis
which is weird because it has been the
most deadly infectious disease for like
99 of the last 10 000 years like every
once in a while like Spanish flu or the
black death or for a very brief time
there covid will overtake tuberculosis
but then tuberculosis will take its
title back as it has now it's actually a
strong Contender for the oldest
infectious disease so it's been with us
for a long time and I would love to like
read a John Green book about it like you
are definitely the expert on this one
not long ago I thought tuberculosis was
like pneumonia where it was like
describing more symptoms like a thing
that happened to the body rather than a
specific disease but no tuberculosis is
caused by a specific bacteria and there
are a bunch of reasons why this bacteria
is extra good at being bad but one of
the big big ones is this this is the
cell wall of the tuberculosis bacteria
and if you think that that looks like a
weird look can sell wall you're right
it's weird looking it's weirdly thick it
is in many different ways the
tuberculosis bacteria's secret weapon
this big thick cell wall That's composed
of largely like waxy fats makes it so
much harder to fight tuberculosis in so
many different weirdly different ways so
first of all you could guess maybe get
some of the obvious ways like it's a big
fat cell wall so it's hard to get stuff
through it into the cell like
antibiotics that might kill that cell
but also a lot of antibiotics work
specifically by attacking the cell wall
of bacteria it's very different from the
cell membranes of people so you can go
after that specific weird thing about
bacteria and break it and then the
bacteria dies but that works on normal
cell walls so because the cell wall is
so different a lot of antibiotics just
don't work as well on TB and then
there's some slightly less obvious ways
that this cell wall helps out
tuberculosis like for example we think
that it makes it like easier for it to
create biofilms like really strong
biofilms where lots of bacteria work
together to create bike structures that
are broader than individual bacteria
biofilms make it harder for antibiotics
to get in and harder for immune cells to
get in allowing the tuberculosis to
figure out how to like hold on for a
really long time inside the body and
also having a bigger weirder cell wall
gives the tuberculosis bacteria more
opportunities to evolve resistance to
antibiotics there's just more places for
resistance to evolve it's called cell
wall Remodeling and TB is really good at
it but then there's like in my head the
really surprising ways that this helps
out tuberculosis because this cell wall
is so big and complicated it's actually
very difficult to manufacture which
means that tuberculosis grows really
slowly like it replicates much more
slowly than most bacteria which sounds
like it would make it worse at being a
pathogen but no so first of all a lot of
antibiotics target fast replicating
cells and tuberculosis just isn't a fast
replicating cell so those antibiotics
are less good at attacking tuberculosis
but second and this is the a really
weird one and it's just a flaming
coincidence we in order to treat
tuberculosis have to figure out whether
a person has tuberculosis and if so what
kind they have and what antibiotics it
might be resistant and to do that you
have to take like the spit of a person
and see what bacteria grows in a Petri
dish and this is easy for most bacteria
because the bacteria grows super fast
like a well-fed E coli Colony will
double in size every 20 minutes for
tuberculosis that takes about a day in
order to diagnose tuberculosis you have
to grow it in the petri dish and to see
if it's resistant to antibiotics you
have to do that a bunch of different
times exposing it to a bunch of
different antibiotics which is just a
lot of human labor like it takes a lot
of time a lot of petri dishes and a lot
of space which would be fine if like a
thousand people a year got tuberculosis
but like 10 million people a year get
tuberculosis but we have now sequenced a
bunch of different TB strains and we
know the sequences that are responsible
for antibiotic resistant and that allows
us with this machine to run a sample
through a little card cartridge that
will tell you if those genetic sequences
are there that tells you two things one
that it's tuberculosis and two whether
or not it's resistant to antibiotics
that machine can do tons of different
tests for tons of different diseases and
it does those tests all over the world
but since TV is the world's most deadly
infectious disease and since it largely
hits in communities that do not have a
lot of resources because it kills
millions of people per year and disables
many more and has been doing that for
many many many years it is so so so
important that we get the cost of these
tests as low as possible specifically
for multi-drug resistant TP which is
just a very dangerous disease for
everybody in the world in large part
because of its weird cell wall
tuberculosis is just really good at
evolving resistance to antibiotics to
save lives and for the safety of
everybody on this planet we need to get
the cost of the tests down and I think
that we can do that and by we I mean all
of us but I also mean the people at
danaher and cepheid who have worked hard
on setting their pricing models and who
I'm sure have lots of targets they've
been asked to hit who absolutely can I
think take a hard look at the
spreadsheets and ask what's the right
thing to do and how can we get the cost
of a multi-drug resistant TB cartridge
down to like five dollars we are not
enemies here we are allies the enemy is
tuberculosis so let's do it John I'll
see you on Tuesday